bonsoir à tous voici les titres de
l'actualité de ce dimanche d accidents
de la route en séries ce week-end un peu
partout en france plus de 10 morts ces
dernières heures
les victimes sont âgées de 15 à 26 ans
les jeunes et la route
quelles solutions la prévention la
répression jean louis borloo ministre en
charge du dossier nous répondra il est
notre invité ce soir barack obama en
passe d'être le super candidat démocrate
grâce au super délégué le candidat dans
la course à l'investiture de vence pour
la première fois son adversaire auprès
des cadres de son parti
reste à savoir si hillary clinton entend
jeter l'épongé
nous irons aux états unis les
conséquences du cyclone sur la birmanie
la communauté internationale parle de
désastre humanitaire
et malgré cela la junte birmane elle se
félicite du succès du référendum qui
l'organisé où en sont les secours
humanitaires nous verrons cela avec le
grand format de ce soir en france le
gouvernement réfléchit à une
réhabilitation des fusillés pour
l'exemple de la première guerre mondiale
la question fait débat depuis des années
nous verrons ce soir qui étaient ces
hommes
enfin quelques jours de l'ouverture du
festival de cannes
un petit cadeau pour les fans de james
bond le dernier opus est en tournage
mais notre équipe a pu se rendre sur
place
première image à suivre à la fin de
cette édition je vous le disais en titre
c'est donc un week end meurtrier qui
vient de se dérouler sur les routes de
france treize personnes ont trouvé la
mort dans l'oise en moselle dans le
calvados ou encore près de tarbes et il
y à un élément en commun à toutes ces
victimes leur âge ils avaient tous moins
de 30 ans pauline d'ordi days in paris
que millar
ils étaient cinq dans la voiture le
conducteur âgé de 36 ans avait bu fumé
du cannabis et conduisait trop vite
voilà ce qu'il reste de leur véhicule il
a percuté un poteau
c'est plusieurs tonneaux les quatre
passagers sont morts
ils avaient entre 15 et 26 ans dans
l'oise près d'ars 6 à 7 heures ce matin
trois jeunes majeurs ont heurté de plein
fouet ce panneau de signalisation
ils sont tous décédés les gendarmes
pensent que le conducteur s'est endormi
en roulant dans le cher près de
saint-amand une voiture s'est encastrée
dans un arbre deux morts et un blessé
dans l'orne près de camp des jeunes
majeurs circuler sur ce chemin longeant
la rivière
leur véhicule est tombé dans l'eau deux
d'entre eux sont morts
le troisième passager a réussi à
s'extraire en ce week-end de pentecôte
les gendarmes multiplient les contrôles
sur les routes de france
la journée de demain est classé rouge le
trafic s'annonce encore très chargé
alors on le sait bien souvent chez les
jeunes l'alcool et dans une majorité des
cas à l'origine des drames dans un
instant nous en parlerons avec le
ministre de l'écologie jean-louis borloo
le gouvernement a déjà mis en place
différentes mesures répressives ou
préventives
l'une d'entre elles souvenez vous
concerne la vente d'éthylotests à 1 euro
estelle colin valérie qu'à souffler pour
prouver aux gendarmes que l'on est en
état de conduire les français
connaissent vous êtes confiant tout à
fait vous avez vu combien
trois rivières on voit également un des
jeunes qui se soumettent avec vraiment
le sourire aux contrôles en disant ben
moi je souffle il ya pas de problème
c'est moi qui conduis je n'ai pas vu une
seule goutte d'alcool
il y a quelques mois le gouvernement a
mis sur le marché un union d'éthylotests
à 1 euro ils permettent aux
automobilistes de s'autocontrôler dans
cette pharmacie parisienne
ces tests se vendent au compte gouttes
on en vend très peu et de moins en moins
dans les boîtes de nuit également ils en
ont ils font souffler les gens au moment
où ils quittent club a tenu donc les
gens ont tendance à ne plus les acheter
eux mêmes
alors il pourrait être question de
souffler pour que sa voiture accepte de
démarrer cet appareil mesure
l'alcoolémie dans l'air expiré
si le seuil autorisé dépassé la voiture
est bloquée impossible de faire démarrer
le moteur et l'appareil me demandent de
remettre de couper le contact
donc il était impossible pour moi de
démarrer autres catégories concernées
les cars scolaires au 1er janvier 2009
tous devront être équipés d'un
éthylotest antidémarrage dans cette
entreprise par exemple c'est tolérance
zéro
dès qu'on a un problème on licencié sur
le champ la zone ya pas de tolérance sur
la pour l'alcool
l'alcool est impliqué dans un quart des
accidents de la route cela représente
1200 morts par an est avec nous jean
louis borloo bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous tout d'abord est ce pont on a un
premier bilan de ces éthylotests
est ce que les jeunes les achète coûté
où on a un bilan parce que un million
ont été mises en circulation la moitié
haute été vendus d'une manière générale
on essaie de mettre en place les
éthylotests antidémarrage heures d'ores
et déjà il ya des pelles des
alternatives si vous avez un délit de
conduite en état d'ivresse le tribunal
peut vous interdire d'avoir une voiture
qui n'est pas équipé
on espère la généralisation très
prochainement alors malheureusement j'ai
envie de dire le chiffre du jour c'est
13 morts oui c'est ça exceptionnel c'est
saissac est affreux parce que en réalité
traitement par jour c'est nos tristes la
moyenne c'est deux fois moins quatre ans
j'ai lancé une campagne à quatre jours
et j'ai entendu des commentaires me
disant mais pourquoi vous lancer une
campagne mois dernier au moins trois
pour cent morts mais ce mois je suis
personnellement investi dans cette
personnellement j'étais touché
personnellement par ce drame et cette
campagne que nous voulons c'est la
campagne du coup de fil savez ce coup-ci
impossible c'est une campagne pour ceux
qui restent
pour ceux qui reçoivent le coup de fil
on leur annonce la mort le drame d'un
verger de 22-23 de 24 25 ans va regarder
un extrait de cette campagne peut vous
avez nous en parler après on va le
regarder tout de suite et un break gris
métallisé
pourquoi sa fille quoi commencer un
accident nous pouvons tous arrêter ça
alors faisons le
alors pourquoi ce message ce que jusqu'à
présent dans les fier des campagnes qui
avait marché mais qui montre l accident
violents dus à l'accident lui-même
là on a voulu parler tout le monde à
tous ceux dont on a tous des exemples de
ce coup de fil qui change la vie
on vous annonce tous responsables on est
tous absolument concerne alors on met
des moyens considérables de répression
michèle alliot-marie ans mais je peux
vous annoncer que demain au conseil
d'état roselyne bachelot adresse avec
moi un décret qui va rendre obligatoire
dans tous les débits de boissons qui où
jusqu'à 2 heures du matin en gros les
bandes l'accord avec les professionnels
boîte de nuit bois des éthylotests
électroniques obligatoire pour que
chacun quand ils sourds puisse tester sa
situation son état pour que son copain
puisse lui attend écoute test regarde
alors on fait avec les professionnels on
l'a testé pour 350 sites et pourtant
joué sont d'accord accueillir ces i télé
oui parce que même son conscience je
dirais même c'est un peu du grand
décompte vous vous à vous avez un
endroit de fête
et puis vous avez sat inquiétudes et
cette angoisse donc dès demain ce sera
au conseil d'état j'espère que pour
l'été
ça sera obligatoire dans tous les débits
de boisson de l'alcool les stupéfiants
également on l'a vu encore ce week end
bruit et la chancellerie adressé une
circulaire sur le dépistage en matière
de stupéfiants
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que même
si c'est pas peu populaire nous on ne
lâchera pas moi je
je suis prêt à accepter l'impopularité
pour ce sujet là mais en même temps ou
delà des radars ou de la sq et de ce qui
est fait par les forces de l'autre ou
delà des contrôles et notamment des
contrôles qui va être beaucoup plus
sévère le samedi soir
au delà de ça c'est un problème
personnel pour évasion et c'est à ce
moment là même de responsabilité et puis
dès cet été
nous devons tous avoir un gilet fluo et
intrusion voilà deux cars gilet fluo
parce que quand on descend de voiture
parce qu'on est en panne
là on a un risque absolument et c'est
important de faire ce point ce soir
merci à vous et justement autre accident
cette fois l'occasion d'un rallye dans
l'aisne près de 63 spectateurs ont été
gravement blessées par une voiture qui a
quitté la piste parmi eux deux jeunes
garçons de 4 et 6 ans une enquête a été
ouverte dans l'actualité de ce dimanche
à l'étranger au liban le calme est
précaire dans la capitale le hezbollah a
certes entamé son retrait dans le
quartier ouest de beyrouth
mais des affrontements ont eu lieu dans
l'est de la ville affrontements
également au nord du pays aux abords de
la ville côtière de tripoli ce matin
entre partisans du gouvernement et
l'opposition
on retrouve à beyrouth gérard griesbeck
bonsoir gérard alors est ce que la
tension est toujours palpable ce soir au
liban oui effectivement elle est
toujours pas le pas vous savez faut
toujours se méfier au liban tout peut
avoir là où on peut avoir l'impression
tout va bien et subitement c'est
l'affrontement
il faut savoir quand même que ce pays
n'a plus de président de la république
depuis six mois
depuis le mois de novembre on est
maintenant au 18e tour de scrutin qui ne
donne rien à l'assemblée nationale donc
en réalité les affrontements se sont
déplacés vous l'avais dit dans la grande
ville du nord du liban qui est tripoli
qui est la grande ville sunnite c'est la
deuxième ville du pays
franchement également se sont déplacés
dans la montagne tenu par à majorité
druze dont vous voyez que ce ne sont pas
simplement des affrontements entre
partisans du gouvernement et hesbollah
pro iranien et pro syriens se sont
également d'autres communautés qui sont
en guerre et à tout moment ça peut
déraper
alors la partie de bras de fer
visiblement va continuer et au milieu de
cette partie de bras de fer et bien il
ya l'armée libanaise qui pour le moment
n'est pas intervenu c'est un peu
l'énigme
ils sont plusieurs dizaines de milliers
de soldats est il issu peut-être viendra
de leur détermination peut-être à passer
d'un côté ou d'un autre côté entre les
pro gouvernementaux les
antigouvernementaux merci gérard aux
états unis maintenant et si les jeux
étaient faits côté démocrate barack
obama
en tout cas franchi une nouvelle étape
il est désormais pour la première fois
en tête dans la chasse aux super
délégués et la question maintenant que
l'on est en droit de se poser
hillary clinton ira-t-elle jusqu'au bout
à new york le reportage de nos
correspondants martine laroche-joubert
et pascal geoffrion course en tête pour
barack obama ici sur un gymnase dans
l'état de l'oregon
il vient de dépasser hillary clinton
dans le match des superbes et déclic je
ferais mieux de rester dans la course
encore plus motivé ce matin dans son
dernier meeting
nous ne pouvons pas attendre pour
réduire le réchauffement de la planète
pour sauver nos rivières et nos forêts
nous ne pouvons pas attendre pour
terminer la guerre en irak
nous ne pouvons pas attendre c'est pour
ça que je veux être président ici et
maintenant nous ne pouvons pas attendre
même à new york le fief d'hillary elle
est sénatrice ici de lui presque huit
ans la course entre les deux candidats
paraît maintenant joué d'avancé
elle n'a aucune chance de gagner son vin
versés le vote populaire est retourné en
sa faveur les super délégué illarine à
temps perdu
je pense que barak va l'emporter hilary
à une bataille impossible je pense qu'à
l'automne sera obama contre ma came
naissance ou jour de fête des mères aux
états unis chelsea la fille d'hillary
soutient sa maman le plus grand voeu de
ma mère elle d'être président celle ci
sera peut-être la dernière à y croire
la ténacité est affaire de famille en
tant que jeune électrice et jeune femme
je suis convaincu que ma mère est la
meilleure candidate et sera la meilleure
la plupart des journaux désigne déjà
novateur hillary clinton demeure la
favorite pour la moitié des 6 dernières
primaires mais c'est pas suffisant
c'est là un coup de théâtre peut changer
la donne autre information qui fait la
une de l'actualité au jour deux états
unis ce sont les nouvelles tornades qui
ont frappé les états de l'oklahoma du
missouri et de la géorgie le bilan est
déjà de 21 morts et les dégâts matériels
sont importants comme vous le voyez sur
ces images
la birmanie la junte au pouvoir se
targue aujourd'hui du succès du
référendum qu'elle a maintenue malgré le
drame qui se joue dans son pays
le bilan du cyclone est toujours de près
de cent mille morts les journalistes
sont toujours interdits sur le
territoire il entre dans la
clandestinité c'est le cas de notre
consoeur de france24 nice bout ça voyons
avec elle où on est l'aide humanitaire
ici en birmanie l'aide humanitaire
continue à arriver effectivement au
compte gouttes mais surtout elle
parvient très peu dans les zones et puis
les coûts frais en l'occurrence le
centre et le sud du bassin de
l'irrawaddy il faut distinguer la
situation dans à rangoon et dans ses
proches environs où l'aide par bien
qu'elles soient gouvernementales ou
vient de la part des ong ou encore aussi
où la population contribue par exemple à
aider les plus sinistrées comme ici où a
lieu actuellement une distribution
alimentaire pour pour les enfants qui a
été organisée par par quelques
villageois
en revanche dans le sud du pays c'est le
black out total c'est à dire que les
voies de circulation sont de nouveau
praticable est ouverte mais l'armée a
mis des check points pour empêcher toute
occidentale d'approché en particulier
des occidentaux humanitaires comme si la
junte voulait empêcher tout témoin
gênant qui pourrait rendre compte de
l'échec de la gestion de la crise mais
prenons maintenant la direction de la
frontière entre la thaïlande et la
birmanie là où le pont humanitaire est
en train justement d'organiser nos
envoyés spéciaux
loïc de la mornais bruno carette sont
allés à la rencontre des carènes ils
font partie de ces opposants au régime
birman c'est le grand format de ce
dimanche soir
si l'armée thaïlandaise multiplient les
contrôles ce n'est pas seulement parce
que la birmanie est juste derrière cette
montagne mais surtout parce que les
habitants de ce village sont une épine
diplomatique
ils vivent en thaïlande depuis des
années mais ce sont des birmans de
l'ethnie karen leurs peuples mènent une
rébellion contre la junte militaire
birmane depuis plus de 40 ans statut
ambigu de tous les réfugiés leur village
est un camp garder et même s'ils peuvent
en sortir il reste des citoyens de
seconde zone
de cette maison s'échappe leurs prières
c'est une église la moitié des carènes
sont chrétiens ici pas de télévision
ils savent ce qu'il s'est passé quelque
chose dans leur ancienne patrie mais
c'est nous qui leur apprendront le
terrible kg cette femme dès qu'il s'agit
d'un phénomène naturel et pense qu'il ya
peut-être quelques milliers de morts
vous d'étudier à cent mille morts c'est
terrible de toute façon les militaires
s'en moquent ils ont pris tout le
pouvoir pour eux ils nous ont toujours
utilisé nous les carènes comme des
esclaves
quelques habitants sont mieux informés
grâce à internet via le téléphone solo
lui préfère cacher son ordinateur par
sécurité cet ancien étudiant
contestataire et c'est sans volage
d'obtenir des nouvelles
j'ai essayé d'appeler plein de voix mes
amis ma famille des communications qui
coupait regardez vous savez ce qui
arrive ça n'est pas juste une
catastrophe naturelle
c'est la catastrophe d'une gestion
politique désastreuse le résultat d'un
régime brutal et corrompu qui n'a même
pas su inverser sa population un
militaire thaïlandais fait irruption et
abrège interview nous sommes expulsés du
camp l'armée thaïlandaise veut éviter
toute publicité à ces réfugiés
diplomatiquement gênant un peu plus au
sud
voici la ville frontalière de maïs haute
ville thaïlandaise mais où 80% de la
population est d'origine birmane
nous avons rendez vous avec un leader de
l'opposition birmane
ce scooter nous guide discrètement les
espions de la junte militaire sont
nombreux ici pour raisons de sécurité
la maison des opposants ne doit pas être
filmés
à l'intérieur - est-il zone est
consterné en regardant la télévision
birmane
ils ne font que manipuler la situation
ils politisent une catastrophe or ce
n'est pas de la politique c'est une
crise humanitaire
ce proche donc sans dessous qui la
célèbre prix nobel de la paix explique
cyniquement le blocage de l'aide
humanitaire étrangère le savez c'est
comme un animal en cage
si vous voulez le dresser contrôler sa
nourriture
eux c'est pareil pour se maintenir au
pouvoir et les utilisent larmes de la
fin voici la birmanie un régime
obsédé par la politique et le mythe de
l'autosuffisance
pour s'y rendre de thaïlande il suffit
d'emprunter ce pour nous avons tenté de
le franchir
mais avons été immédiatement refoulés
nous avons alors confié notre caméra à
notre guide interprète thaïlandaise elle
a réussi à passer
voici la petite ville birmane de
myawaddy
ici le typhon ne s'est pas abattue
en ce week end électoral ce bourg de
province et surtout accaparée par le
référendum sur ce bus de campagne on
peut lire pour être de bons citoyens
voter oui pour la nouvelle constitution
arme au poing des militaires
patrouillant pick-up échange de
banalités avec le cyclo pousse ici
personne n'ose parler du typhon et
encore moins du pouvoir ce serait bien
trop dangereux
au même moment côté thaïlandais c'est
presque un exploit qui ça compte
c'est deux camions de l'onu chargée des
d'humanitaire sont autorisés à passer
nous y allons pas à pas malheureusement
nous devons faire avec ce système
j'espère que les virements nous
donneront de plus en plus de place et
que les autres organisations
humanitaires pourront enfin apporter
leur aide
ce chauffeur thaïlandais dit qu'il est
fier d'apporter l'aide aux sinistrés
sa joie sera de courte durée il sera
remplacé amy pond par un producteur
birman si la route est semée d'obstacles
pour les humanitaires le no man's land
en dessous est une vraie passoire pour
les petits trafics en tous genres au
pied de la rambarde frontières c'est
birman vendent des cigarettes de
l'alcool et même des médicaments un
marché noir aux grands comment expliquez
vous que les cigarettes qui se passait
la frontière et paris pour les victimes
du typhon
pas de réponse comme pour indiquer
chacun sa misère c'est proche et si
lointaine à la fois
la birmanie est là à moins de 200 m les
secours regardent impuissants cette
petite rivière
si dérisoire et pourtant si
infranchissable c'est l' empire des
généraux roi du bus un royaume où les
bouteilles de whisky passe mais pas les
bidons d'eau enfants ce dimanche le port
des sables d'olonne étaient toujours
bloqués par plusieurs chalutier qui ont
pris position aux goûts du chenal est
les marins pêcheurs évoque une nouvelle
fois le gazole trop cher et constatent
que leur travail n'est plus rentable il
en appelle à nouveau au gouvernement va
les jeunes rouge
ces plaisanciers se doit ont dû prendre
leur mal en patience
impossible de sortir du port des sables
d'olonne aujourd'hui parce qu'il y à la
grèce
sept chalutiers bloquent les entrées et
sorties avec un câble tendu au milieu du
chenal il réclame un nouveau coup de
main de l'état face à la hausse du prix
du gazole on est à 2 tonnes par jour de
traîner nos chats lui donc ça représente
à peu près sur une marée de dix jours 14
généraux vue en ce moment au plus six
bateaux qui arrivent tous à vatan
bruxelles nous bloque de partout on a
plus de quotas ont pas pu faire
construire ce total en novembre dernier
la profession s'était déjà mobilisée
pour les mêmes raisons un plan d'urgence
étaient mises en place avec une taxe de
2 % sur l'achat de poissons en grandes
surfaces qui devrait rapporter 80
millions d'euros par an aux pêcheurs
insuffisant estiment ceux des sables
d'olonne qui espèrent être rejoints par
des marins d'autres ports ces images de
la plage de roquebrune cap martin qui
est touchée par des boulettes
d'hydrocarbure plusieurs plages de la
côte d'azur sont concernées notamment
celles de beaulieu et de cap d'antibes
on ignore pour le moment l'origine de
cette pollution
la politique olivier besancenot le porte
parole de la lcr était cet après midi
l'invité de michel drucker dans son
émission vivement dimanche et au même
moment
arlette laguiller prononcée elle son
traditionnel discours pour la fête de
lutte ouvrière à presles dans le val
d'oise
reportage sur place thierry kurt et
daniel lévy elle 30 minutes au nord de
paris
c'est d'abord une fête de famille pour
lutte ouvrière arlette laguiller y est
interpellé
comme une mère une cousine que l'on
retrouve un an après on lui parle
surtout licenciements et plans sociaux
pour le profit des actionnaires
pas pour les fruits du travail cette
année l'on dit elle plus encore que les
années précédentes
elle sent les militants inquiets qu'ils
subissent une dégradation économique
accélérée quand on pense que un chômeur
sur deux n'est pas indemnisée
aujourd'hui et qu'on voit à côté de ça
les profits énormes des grandes
entreprises ont je crois que l'urgence
est vraiment une lutte d'ensemble du
monde du travail pour faire reculer le
patronat et faire reculer le
gouvernement qui a finalement simplement
la voix de ce grand patronat dans les
stands
le fond de ce discours fait l'unanimité
mais certains s'interrogent sur la
manière de porter ces idées de la gauche
de la gauche
cela regarde grandir l'écho médiatique
de l'autre voix d'extrême gauche olivier
besancenot
indéniablement il a il ne peut plus
l'arrêter plus grande car les aiguiller
mais ce débat là restent feutrées sous
le chapiteau karl marx le thème favori
cette année cette grève chef baïse et
mai 68 grand choix révolutionnaire non
aboutis vrai moment de fierté
on voudrait bien ici que l'histoire
repasse les plats
mai 68 justement avec ce soir le
témoignage d'un crs il avait 24 ans à
l'époque des événements il reconnaît
aujourd'hui qu'il aurait pu être
de l'autre côté des barricades des
souvenirs et un témoignage recueilli par
françois privat et fabien d'ormuz gay
lussac la nuit des barricades
jusqu'à présent camille vandier n'en a
jamais parlé
ce 10 mai 1968 en provenance de la
rochelle le crs de 24 ans découvrent la
capitale et l'hostilité ambiante de
cette fin d'après midi en mairie de
laissac pour pouvoir arriver à compris à
100 150 mètres de la barricade
pour conclure il fallait une gaieté au
balcon et en suède et tout ce qui
pouvait servir d'objets mais pour fleur
des dix mille étudiants c'est dans les
rues engagés dans une lutte acharnée
avec les policiers on avait chargé pour
la première fois par une volée de palets
que c'était pas c'était pas de la
rigolade moukrim fait dès l'éclatement
des grenades de les jeunes enfants
peuvent également écrire ça s'agitait
partout sa cour en plus mes posters et
coupez en était en noir vous riez pas
très bien ce qu'on faisait dans les
hauteurs de lacrymogènes peter autant
qu'au contenu manifestants après une
vingtaine d'heures de chaos
c'est la relève et le retour au
cantonnement où quelques jours plus tard
ce sont des balles réelles que l'on
distribue à l'ensemble de la compagnie
quand on commence à vous trouver des
balles réelles des balles réelles de
bouche que tant dans des emballages par
apulée puisqu'il faut compter avec bien
sûr que nous admettions renouer avec
l'or de mieux s'en servir que sur ''les
enjeux de cette ville est vrai quand
même de questions je pense que là je me
suis rendu compte qu'on avait vraiment
frôlé la nuit des barricades à tout
jamais un traumatisme pour camille
vandier qui en 1970 quitte les crs pour
poursuivre sa carrière au sein d'un
commissariat
l'histoire de france n'en a peut-être
pas fini avec la première guerre
mondiale ainsi une partie des 600 poilus
fusillés pour l'exemple pourrait être un
jour réhabiliter le débat avait été
lancé par lionel jospin en son temps et
et voilà qu'il s'invite à nouveau au
coeur de l'actualité jean marie bockel
le secrétaire d'état aux anciens
combattants ne rejette pas l'idée d'une
réhabilitation
mais au cas par cas une question simple
ce soir qui sont ces hommes fusillés
pour l'exemple explications frédéric
montagne chloé cormery léonard leymarie
34 ans fusillés pour l'exemple
le 12 décembre 1914 le conseil de guerre
l'accusent de s'être volontairement
mutilé la main c'était là beaucoup de
soldats se mutile pour pour échapper à
échapper aux combats et puis elle marie
a été blessé il semblerait qu'il soit
fort militaire mutilé volontairement on
va le passer en conseil derrière et il
va être un hiver
condamné à mort exécuté alors que les
maris il est exécuté parce qu'il s'est
blessé à la main oui en quatre ans de
guerre 2400 poilus furent condamnés à
mort par l'armée accusés de désertion
lâcheté mutinerie 600 d'entre eux furent
fusillés certains sols a refusé de
mourir dans des offensives vouée à
l'échec comme celle de 1917 n'est qu'un
nageur lui redouter de voir ses troupes
fuir les combats
j'ai assisté au procès un déjà et pour
l'exemple il est dégradé à mort il est
éveillé
le lieutenant accusés - des tirs et la
tête au visage sévère nécessaire de
chercheurs de la save et de la france
sinon c'est à baillargues
aujourd'hui le gouvernement veut se
plonger dans les archives et réhabiliter
ces soldats longtemps oublié mais
seulement au cas par cas sur le site
sont fusillés de la guerre de 14
la plupart l'ont été après des jugements
pour crimes de droit commun assassinats
violents malheureusement tout ce qui se
passe dans une guerre et une minorité
d'entre eux a été fusillé pour l'exemple
réhabiliter des soldats injustement
condamné lionel jospin l'avait déjà
tenté il y a dix ans en vain en
angleterre il a fallu de longues années
de débats avant que 306 fusillé soit
innocenté
depuis deux ans il dispose enfin d'un
monument aux morts la page cinéma avant
d'aller à cannes pour suivre les
préparatifs avant l'ouverture du
festival mercredi voici les premières
images du prochain james bond qui ne
sortira qu'en novembre notre équipe a pu
se rendre sur le tournage en autriche le
héros c'est toujours daniel craig mais
le méchant c'est un français et c'est
mathieu amalric qui l'incarnent
reportage françois jullien pieds noirs
des cascades des gadgets encore des
cascades des voitures sublime des filles
aussi sublime que les voitures
pas de doute on est bien sur le tournage
du nouveau james bond et voici le
casting de ce 22e épisode
daniel craig reprend le rôle de 007 la
james bond girl s'appelle olga kurylenko
né en ukraine elle vit à paris le
méchant vous savez il y en a toujours un
james bond c'est le français mathieu
amalric et en bas à droite bas c'est
juste moi pour vous prouver qu'on était
bien sûr le tournage en autriche
mais le scénario est top secret ce que
l'on sait c'est que l'action commence
quelques minutes après la fin de casino
royale le dernier épisode où l'on avait
découvert un james bond à nouveau les
humains james bond a été trahie qu'à
doubler par une fille derrière il y
avait une organisation qui tentait de
contrôler 0,07 et le monde est donc dans
ce nouveau film james bond est dans un
état d'esprit de vengeance est une
vengeance qui le mènera un certain
monsieur green interprété par mathieu
amalric un dandy écologiste qui veut
faire main basse sur les ressources
naturelles de la planète
un méchant smoking et souriant pas de
cicatrice pas de ce qui nous faisait
très très peur pas de chat blanc soussou
et papa de metal de deux bleus mâchoire
métal quelque chose beaucoup plus terne
ont tâché et c'est peut-être encore plus
dangereux côté coeur on nous a dit qu'il
y aurait des surprises avec la james
bond girl
explications de celle qui ressemble
étrangement à sophie marceau ancienne
james bond girl aussi c'est le rôle
d'une femme très forte et qui est très
indépendante est assez assez déterminés
dans ce qu'elle fait c'est pas seulement
physiques n'ont pas dit oh non non pas
du tout vous hésitez donc à paris oui
que j'ai des chances de croiser james
bond girl à paris prendre un verre avec
elle à montmartre par exemple mais mia
sur au fait ce james bond estimé à près
de 230 millions de dollars s'appellera
cuenta mof soleil si en français traduit
par source de réconfort
sorti en france le 5 novembre 2008 voilà
et comme chaque dimanche voici
maintenant le classement des films au
premier jour de leur sortie cette
semaine en tête jackpot une comédie
américaine avec cameron diaz et ashton
kutcher en deuxième position autre
comédie tu ne peux garder un secret
d'alexandre arcady pigalle du nom de ce
groupe antiterroriste luttant contre le
thé à un sim espagnol avec josé garcia
et enfin un bataille à seattle qui
revient sur les manifestations contre la
conférence de l'om c'est qu'ils ont eu
lieu dans la ville
en 99 le cinéma toujours dans trois
jours le festival de cannes 2008
s'ouvrira et la ville souvent plutôt
paisible deviendra pour la 61e fois le
carrefour du cinéma mondial
un moment à part que tout le monde
prépare à sa façon sur place vincent
capus et niels bohr delhi sous les
palmiers c'est encore le chantier comme
chaque année quand arrive le mois de mai
cannes se métamorphose en capitale
mondiale du septième art pendant quinze
jours sa population va tripler passant
de 70 mille à deux cent mille habitants
les stars s'affichent déjà sur les murs
des palaces et à l'intérieur tout est
prêt pour leur arrivée nous sommes ici
dans l'appartement de monsieur woody
allen
nous attendons très prochainement pour
l'ouverture du festival de cannes une
suite avec vue à plus de 4000 euros la
nuit à ce prix là on ne refuse rien à
ses hôtes de luxe ça peut aller du nom
particulière une type de fruits bien
spécifiques etc de façon à pouvoir
contenter des l'arrivée les personnes
que nous accueillons woody allen
penélope cruz georges aucun pour indiana
jones
à deux pas de la croisette chez ce
loueur de voitures avec chauffeurs ont
fait briller les belles carrosseries
dans quelques jours le personnel sera
sur le pont jour et nuit la limousine a
toujours la cote
mais la familiale devient tendance on
utilise moins des fois des berlines
luxueuses pour mais plus des monospaces
de luxe ou des minibus de lutte avec des
sièges bébé dedans et des gens viennent
en famille voix qui profite un peu du
festival et puis de découvrir la région
avec leurs enfants
en attendant les célébrités les marches
du palais des festivals jouent les
vedettes
c'est là que se déroulait donc si ça non
à l'accord
c'est bizarre qui ont tendance à la télé
c'est une chose et quand on voit
réellement voilà donc pas quelque chose
encore là si le tapis rouge on voit là
monter les marches aussi ça vous fait
rêver oui voilà weis à mon avis ça
restera du domaine du rêve
entre rêve et réalité à cannes c'est un
peu à chacun son festival
il n'est pas acteur mais c'est aussi un
artiste dans son domaine vous l'avez
peut-être déjà vu à l'oeuvre la nuit
tombée à paris ou ailleurs
il écrit où il est peint avec de la
lumière sur des monuments sur des
inconnus dans la rue étrange vous n'avez
peut-être pas tout compris et bien on
regarde cela en images avec jérôme
bernard et sébastien laffargue
cet homme est un tagueur en série
de l'arc de triomphe à la tour eiffel
tous les monuments parisiens ils sont
passés depuis des mois ils taguent sous
vos yeux et pourtant vous n'avez rien
marko 93 9 ans ni à la bombe ni à la
gouache mais à la lumière
nous retrouvons chez lui à saint denis
en pleine séance et son étrange façon de
peindre
le light painting peinture à la lumière
le light painting j'ai commencé en 99 on
voyant une photo on voit la traîner des
feux de voitures et je me suis dit que
si on arrivait à faire des voitures
arrivent à faire un trait horizontal
moi je pouvais prendre ce trait est
dessiné avec marco utilise donc ces
lampes comme pinceau enroulé ses modèles
de traînée de lumière et prend une photo
ou une vidéo
avec un long temps d'exposition une idée
lumineuse
je pense avoir inventé un grand courant
artistique et à quelques années je suis
tombé sur un cliché du grand photographe
man ray
on le voit en train de faire un light
painting en 1934 et laure devient un
angle son modèle cette nuit est une
drôle de geisha et notre tagueurs
éclairé reprend sa chorégraphie
invisibles à l'oeil nu
c'est dans l'air donc ça ne tache pas ça
reste pas cessé plaisir des yeux quand
un graffiti propre aucune trace
hormis sur la pellicule voilà de quoi
ouvrir certaines portes de nouveaux
terrains de jeu un plateau de télé par
exemple voici le premier présentateur du
20h tagués rassurez vous dans quelques
secondes
tout rentrera dans l'ordre oui c'était
pas mal le sport de ce week-end et
l'actualité c'est essentiellement le
football en france comme en europe
l'heure du sacre approche dans les
différents championnats et c'est
d'ailleurs chose faite en angleterre
manchester united a conservé son titre
on fait le point sur tout cela avec
nathanaël de rincquesen il aurait sans
doute préféré faire ses adieux au public
du parc avec la certitude que le psg
resterait en ligue 1 l'an prochain
pauleta tire sa révérence hier soir face
à saint-etienne il n'a pas inscrit son
dixième but sous le maillot du paris
saint germain dans ce match extrêmement
important pour les deux équipes ce sont
même les verts qui ouvre le score
un peu avant la mi temps en deuxième
période le parisien jérémy clément
égalise d'une volée rageuse et offre à
son club un match nul et un précieux
points dans la lutte pour le maintien
hier soir toulouse et lens se sont
inclinés paris est désormais 16e au
classement avant la dernière journée du
championnat
en quête d'un 7e titre lyon n'est pas
encore sacré hier soir face à nancy le
sextuple champion de france s'est imposé
sur ce but confus n'est tellement
important
les lyonnais conserve deux points
d'avancé sur bordeaux le suspense reste
entier
tout se jouera sur les terrains
d'auxerre et lens le week-end prochain
le football français a tranchant pions
l'angleterre connaît le sien depuis
quelques heures
manchester est sorti vainqueur de son
duel à distance avec chelsea les diables
rouges se sont imposés 2 à 0 sur le
terrain de wigan tandis que chelsea
était tenu en échec par bolton
manchester united pour encore pour dix
septième titre de champion d'angleterre
en italie patrick vieira bien cru offrir
le scudetto à l'inter de milan en
marquant le premier but de la rencontre
face à sienne rejoint au score les
milanais obtiennent un penalty généreux
en fin de rencontre si materazzi marc
lynn terry champion d'italie comme en
france le championnat italien connaîtra
son dénouement le week-end prochain à
materazzi
avant de refermer journal je vous
rappelle l'une des principales
informations du jour c'est la mort sur
les routes ces dernières heures de 13
personnes toutes avaient moins de 30 ans
ce soir sur ce plateau le ministre de
l'écologie jean louis borloo a annoncé
que dès demain le conseil d'état par
décret obligera tous les débits de
poissons et les boîtes de nuit à
s'équiper d'éthylotests afin que chacun
puisse tester son alcoolémie avant de
prendre le volant
voilà pour l'essentiel de l'information
de cette fin de week-end merci à vous
d'avoir suivi ce journal la météo c'est
avec tania young
je suis du cinéma avec will smith et eva
mendes dans hitch expert en séduction
demain à 13 heures elise lucet 20h david
pujadas je vous souhaite une très belle
soirée au revoir